since I was a little kid I was always
fascinated with not just my own origin
you know which is the only story you
come into but the universe and what is
the ultimate potentially the ultimate
origin story of all which is how did
everything come to be to say what
happened on the Tuesday before the Big
Bang that may have an answer for the
first time in history by technology that
my colleagues who are far smarter than I
am are helping to build via What's
called the Simon's Observatory going to
Mars
um is fundamentally I believe an
Escapist you know kind of fantasy do you
think it's pointless is there anything
for us on Mars I guess is what I'm
asking well um so there's there's
something for us right the question is
is that worth the price you'll have to
pay there's a famous quote by one of my
heroes Richard Feynman he said science
is the belief in the ignorance of
experts not the wisdom not the knowledge
of expert but the ignorance of it what
the hell are you talking about Fimo is a
genius Einstein was a genius yeah they
were genius because they doubted came
before them science has never settled
foreign
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our terrific
guest today is a cosmologist which as he
just told us is a branch of astrophysics
Professor Brian Keaton working
trigonometry that's a great pleasure and
honor to be here guys thanks for asking
me it's great to have you on the show
before we get into everything to do with
space and everything that's out there
and not out there uh tell everybody who
are you how are you where you are what's
been your journey through life yeah so I
always like that that uh question that's
become your trademark because it allows
me to segue into what I always ask
people what's the most important day on
the calendar you know I say what is it
usually if you're smart and you're a guy
you'll say my anniversary right or my
wife's birthday but it's always some
kind of origin story right everyone's
fascinated with an origin and since I
was a little kid I was always fascinated
with not just my own origin you know
which is the only story you come into
that you will have to rely on other
people to tell you the truth of what
came before but the universe and what is
the ultimate potentially the ultimate
origin story of all which is how did
everything come to be and it's
interesting because what I do is called
cosmology which a lot of people you know
because of the way that I look and you
know my handsome Visage uh they no I'm
just kidding they think it has
cosmetology so you know if I if I don't
get that I get you know or you're an
astrology astrologer or whatever can you
tell me my horoscope
to say no but now I take opportunity to
actually answer it I say oh you're a
Gemini oh that's really terrible you
know you should have that wart looked at
on the back of your neck there but the
these you know the similarities between
both astrology and astronomy cosmology
and cosmetology are very deep you know
etymology is very important Cosmos means
beauty or face and what I study is the
face that's presented by the universe to
ordinary Mortals to perceive and it's
very beautiful uh and so I've been
fascinated by that on aesthetic level
and never really thinking as a kid when
I was interested got my first telescope
as a you know 10 year old little little
boy that I could do it as a job you know
who's going to pay me to be you know
like essentially the equivalent for
nerds of being an ice cream taster or
you know a wizard or you know or one of
those guys who you know like test a
roller coaster at SeaWorld so I didn't
think you could do it as a job so I was
kind of stymied because I love that I
had this great passion for it all
throughout High School College in
graduate school and even in graduate
school I didn't think I could do what
I'm doing now which is to be a professor
of physics and astronomy at a top
university in Southern California UC San
Diego where I get to teach young people
and work with brilliant people that
teach me things about how the universe
came to be and what's going to happen in
a deep future of our existence and so in
a real way I get paid to ask and answer
and and just grapple with the most
fascinating origin story of them all and
that's how that our universe come to be
well that's an awesome thing to spend
your life doing it's and I can tell you
love it and you're super excited by it
as you know as we sit here recording
this we've just had your friend Eric
Weinstein on the show and one of the
conversations we part of the
conversation we were having was about
um you know pessimism and optimism and
how we see the future of humanity and
and also how we you know our
relationship with the things that you
study actually our relationship with
things beyond Earth and I was saying
that when I was growing up and I imagine
even more when you were growing up
you're 10 years older than I am you know
this idea that our destiny was somehow
beyond Earth was not just universally
accepted it was embedded in literature
it was embedded and cultured that's what
movies were about that's what books were
about you know science fiction really
focused he didn't even focus on like how
we gonna get to the start that that was
kind of like a done deal it was like
when we form a society on another planet
here are some of the challenges or when
we have robots here's some of the moral
quandaries that we'll enter and yet in
my lifetime and in yours it too I think
that seems to have actually been rolled
back and there isn't any more that sense
of Destiny and vision and optimism is
that fair to say I think there is and
there isn't uh there's certainly
optimism you know more so than ever in
terms of space and our future being in
space and ironically I'm more
pessimistic about our future being in
space rather than uh you know people
like Eric or people like Elon Musk and
so forth um and we can get into that but
you know it's it's the old saying the
Optimus builds the airplane the
pessimist builds the parachute and you
know who's to say is more important I
think there's a Temptation because you
sound smart if you're a pessimist and
you sound like just wild eyed naivete if
you say oh we're going to be building
these you know like you had zubrin on
last year earlier and uh you know we're
going to be there in 20 years there's
gonna be a baby born on Mars and I love
his writing I love what he said but I
think it's he's totally off face I mean
I think from a practical standpoint he's
off base and yet and yet I think it's
extremely important to contemplate these
things uh for example people uh in my
department uh Shelly Wright very famous
uh uh astrophysicist she's looking for
signals of extraterrestrial intelligence
using uh flashes of light emitted by
potential lasers you know wielded by
extraterrestrial not in Star Wars but
communicating their presence using it as
some sort of vast internet Intergalactic
Interstellar internet I think that
boggles the mind and in fact is is one
of The Inspirations that may you know
spark a young Brian or you know know
Brianna or somebody now to want to be
get into science which I do think is the
most important thing I think there's no
more important thing and I get into
fights my colleagues in the literature
Department all the time uh you know that
that you know what is the most important
thing to study do we need more
scientists do we need more Engineers do
we need more you know people in the
so-called stem Fields do we need more
people in the humanities to tell us
about meaning and so forth and so for
that I always look back who are the
people that could do both
who are the people like like our friend
Eric Eric can do both he's one of the
most eloquent well-read historically
intelligent intellectuals public
intellectuals talking about you know
Bengali I don't know he can speak in
Russian to you he can he can do all
sorts of you know he can do basic uh you
know play music and uh and it was funny
because you guys were talking about all
like why do we shame people that that
don't play an instrument I was thinking
like I'm pretty good at playing Spotify
that's about where I end up but but do
we need these two cultures a CP snow
used to talk about
um I claim let's look back to the
greatest intellects of History read
principia by Isaac Newton read Michael
Faraday um uh read read my hero who is
Galileo and you'll read things in there
that rival the deepest most enriching uh
poetry a written prose format you think
well what are they talking about
equations with like pendulums what does
that have to no because they were
speculating on things there was no there
was no science in the way that we have
it today there were no journals there
was no peer review as Eric Eric rails
about
um and so you would do things either by
live demonstration so imagine you have a
theory as I'll be speaking tonight I'm
being honored by giving this discourse
at the Royal Institution which is the
oldest continuing dialogue in human
inhumanity civilization that's never
ended since the early 1800s where
speakers come in they're pushed onto
stage and they give a speech and that's
to evoke this notion that this is
science is an evolving so it's never
finished you never reach the end of
science so when I look at that and then
I look at Faraday's writing who's one of
the founding um you know members of the
Royal Institution I read his writing
it's poetic and it's humble and it's
beautiful and I say well you could learn
a lot about literature by reading
Michael Faraday's works on
electromagnetism the invention of the
motor and thoughts about things that
were speculative uh at UC San Diego I'm
delighted to be the associate director
of What's called the Arthur C Clarke
Center for human imagination one of your
great countrymen right uh and Arthur C
Clarke and many of us I mean it's it's
incredible Rich language brilliant ideas
insights a lot of Technology we have
today uh was presaged not invented by
him uh but presaged in many of his books
the iPad geosynchronous satellites of
bases on the moon Ai and all sorts of
other things that we talk about today he
was talking about those 50 or 60 years
ago writing almost as a poet and so I
feel like to be optimistic is to think
and dream about these things you know
and and reach beyond what your grasp is
as Kennedy used to say but at the same
time I think we can have a little bit of
a devolvement into into well let's
escape this place and that's what I'm
worried about so I think we have to
balance the pessimism where you sound
really smart because you can predict the
sky is falling
um and and no one really ever keeps the
receipts you know I actually went back
um and listened to this this podcast by
this guy Sam Harris I don't know if
you've ever heard of that but he had on
this other guy uh Scott Galloway and uh
they were talking about it and it was
like from 2020 or early 2020. they're
talking about how evil it would be if
Trump got elected because you know God
forbid there'd be a war in the Ukraine
probably and I'm just like wait guys do
you ever look back and and check your
predictions and you know so it's easy to
make predictions about things and come
off as as a pseudo-intellectually sound
reason reasoning
um but I think you have to balance that
and humans are awful at balancing things
right we we like polarization we like
going in One Direction the other one
very uncomfortable so being in the
middle there's an old Yiddish saying
that you stand in the middle of the road
you get hit by both sides of the trailer
tell us about it
that being the case do you sometimes get
frustrated at the fact that we seem to
be coming ever more pessimistic even
America the most optimistic nation in
the world is now kind of pessimistic
yeah it isn't it isn't when you look at
uh things politically I I was I was you
know musing with Constantine earlier
today you know that when I got into
astronomy part of it was because you
know you no one wakes up in the morning
and says I hate those damn Republican
constellations over there and oh that
Democratic comet is Gonna Save uh we
don't think like that it's a safe space
from politics so it's not polarized it
can be the overlays of that we can get
into that um because everything at some
level has some notion of politicization
but but that's okay it's manageable uh I
think in terms of optimism there's kind
of this wild-eyed thing or you know just
take the most prominent ones that are
going on right now and you guys have had
conversations about this you had some
with Eric and you've had on others you
know it's AI depopulation uh and then uh
going to Mars right so those are three
very very interesting and unique
conversations that you guys have had and
when I look at that and I think well in
all those cases there's some element of
escapism which is a fundamental
expression of this satisfaction with
where you are now
right if we weren't dissatisfied with
our lot we would have never invented at
my home institution the polio vaccine by
Jonas Salk right we would have said okay
we have to live with this or die with
this or not live with this uh Etc so
dissatisfaction is a Hallmark of of a
civilization the discontent and and sort
of like unwillingness to settle for the
current uh the current Dynamic so I
think that that is a good thing on the
other hand being too wild-eyed and and
you know just take take the Mars example
going to Mars
um is fundamentally I believe a uh an
Escapist you know kind of fantasy do you
think it's pointless
um I wouldn't say it's pointless there
are technological benefits that will
redown to any society that Endeavors to
do something on such a grand uh such a
grand scale uh but but I mean they're
actually going to like yes the project
of making the thing that takes you to
Mars will create new technology and
whatever but is there anything for us on
Mars I guess is what I'm asking you well
um so there's there's something for us
right uh the question is is that worth
the price you'll have to pay so I always
ask you know Elon uh God bless him as 10
kids that we know about so far yeah I
mean what time is that right
um and and I love that I I love his and
he said that you know his he's doing his
part to uh to forestall population
collapse and and I do I do mean that but
on the other hand talking about dying on
Mars who my friend I've had on and you
should interview at some point uh Lord
Martin Reese the astronomer Royal of
this great kingdom here uh he uh he used
to joke with me that you know his job as
astronomer Royal was to tell the queen
her horoscope but he doesn't do that
anymore sadly she's she's deceased so
the the question is you know he said he
wants to die on Mars and and Lord Reese
would say well hopefully it's not on
impact right
so let's just say it's not on impact and
he's going to make it there right so
he's going to get there uh Elon uh which
of your 10 kids are coming with you
which of you either the sort of pilots
on this craft are not is not at all
possible in my humble estimation for it
to be a return trip I mean the minimum
you're talking about at least the better
part of a decade to go there do
something there uh return Voyage you
know the way that the planetary orbits
work out the minimum time duration round
trip would be at least two years maybe
even more all the way you're
experiencing extreme microgravity which
destroys uh your mental capacity it
destroys brain function uh astronauts
come back their bodies are literally as
if they've been you know in a
concentration camp wasting away just
there's no no way to exercise see actual
natural sunlight and then once you get
there you're you're it's not like
Christopher Columbus had to bring
civilization with him to the new world
uh or you know that he couldn't find
things to sustain him there now I know
yes there's carbon dioxide on there
asubrin talked about on this podcast so
carbon dioxide you can use that to make
oxygen and carbon and oh hey life has a
lot of carbon and oxygen in it yeah but
it's not like Columbus had to bring with
him like actual seeds so that when he
got to the door like it started to grow
stuff no there were people living there
watching him discover the new world
right so um but moreover when you look
at the resources that a planetary uh uh
environment can sustain what is it
actually made up of if you took all life
on Earth and all life that's ever
existed so all the biosphere what we
call the biosphere
um and you took it and you you made it
into a creamy vegemite-like paste okay
how thick do you think that would be
like any every dinosaur that ever lived
every amoeba that ever lived every
chlorophyll molecules I ever produced
inside of these lovely plants and bushes
behind us right
um how thick do you think that layer of
the Earth's surface would be
nanometers you know microns what would
it be Demi I mean Francis any idea I
mean
we're going to talk about trigonometry
tell us how it's about four millimeters
really yeah that's all yeah and you've
ever seen the Earth from space like that
that Blue Marble picture some people
have on your screen saver right you're
looking at you know tens of kilometers
you know millions of times bigger layer
of of you know cert and even that is the
so-called Thin Blue Line without that we
don't exist right so so just imagine
like taking that that layer of biosphere
that shell of biology and spreading it
on Martin now Mars is smaller it's a
little bigger than our moon a little bit
smaller than they are um so that would
be a little bit thicker but can you
imagine it I mean can you imagine
transporting that much material or
having unlocking or converting the
carbon dioxide the nitrogen the
phosphorus and DNA and RNA to make a
living biosphere
um so why is this important though why
am I not denying that we should do it uh
I question it as I said I question it on
personal as a father myself you're a
father too constantly right uh I don't
think you are no you're not not yet no
yeah ladies I think uh so
um when you when you have a child your
world changes and by the way you don't
have to have a biological child for your
world you can have an ideological child
you can be a father figure I was an
unclear figure for many years before me
so so the point is what do you leave
behind to go on this one-way Journey
let's stipulate it's possible you could
get there maybe even you'd live
um who are you going to bring with you
what what kind of psychological damage
is that going to do to you uh to leave
people behind so I maybe could say that
just for for
um for Elon maybe he's comfortable with
that or maybe he's not and and he's just
so detached from that sense of reality
but I think for most people it'd be very
hard to do that and then let alone to
convince millions of people to do it to
create a sustainable you know
agriculture you know but then why are
you going there what is the reason
nobody asks ever asked him why he says
we I want to go there it's almost like
he wants to make this Arc it's a it's a
very sort of almost a scatological you
know like he's making this Arc Mars is
The Arc in order for us to be
um and the way I've heard him describe
it I'd love to to talk to him more about
it from I don't think he's talked to a
real physicist you know as far as I can
tell I don't think Joe Rogan you know
qualifies a physicist yet although he's
had um a lot of physicists but the point
being
what are the what are the physical
limitations what what is the purpose of
this well it's the store Consciousness
yes well I say well there are other ways
you can store Consciousness just like
there are other ways you can time travel
did you guys know you can time travel or
right now we're time traveling I don't
mean it like that but uh the the problem
comes in when people want to travel
through time and they want to bring
their bodies with them and they want to
bring the their possessions with them
like some Pharaoh from from you know
from ancient Egypt and so they're greedy
in other words they want to they want to
have their their afterlife and and live
it too and I think that when you step
back and realize you are capable right
now or in the future hopefully you live
a long life but you are capable of
living a very long time
um and it's not you know as uh as Woody
Allen said I don't want to live on in
the in the minds of my countrymen I want
to live on in my apartment in Brooklyn
uh in this case it's it's it's through
the impact and the connections that you
make on Earth right now by connecting to
People by by nurturing relationships and
establishing uh the the geometrical
explosion of connection and meaning that
comes from from relationships that's all
gone when you're on Mars you're talking
about three other people four other
people if that I mean it might just be
one person right um and so so the
question is what is the goal well where
does Consciousness reside is
consciousness Universal like can you
store it on a flash drive
um you know can we upload it our AI is
conscious I've been playing around a lot
with these uh we can talk about those
and and the potential well I know Eric's
expressed you know some some concerns
about them and others Elan as well
um so so what is a goal nobody ever
really gets it well no I I mean if I was
to steal man what I perceive as elon's
argument is yes okay you can download
the sum of human knowledge onto a flash
drive and launch it into space where it
can be like you know a message and a
bottle for the rest of Eternity and you
could argue that's Consciousness but
it's not self-replicating right it's
Frozen in Time whereas what he's talking
about is survival of humanity uh
whereby if we all have a nuclear war
here on Earth there'll be you know seven
people on Mars who are able to reproduce
and and survive on right so so there's
two approaches right and I agree with
you although it is possible to you know
if there there's a an explanation for
the origin of life is a very mysterious
thing we actually don't know about it
they're people that stipulate that life
you know spontaneously originated some
of the work done uh by uh late uh
professors at UC San Diego Miller and
Yuri established this primordial
chemistry primordial Earth-like
environment and they put in some goop
and they've shocked it with electrodes
and out came you know these little
neanders that would be pretty surprising
uh but it was some amino acids yes
precursors to life anyway
um it turns out that that experiment had
a lot of um uh incorrect assumptions
about what the Earth was like anyway uh
the point being that the the history of
the earth is intimately related to the
life that's inhabited and actually the
life that four millimeter layer is
probably the most consequential of all
the geographic strata that that one
would encounter going you know drilling
down to the core of the earth
essentially and it's a relic of what we
call the anthropocene you know when the
hominids have existed so the question is
does that encode it you know does DNA
encode it what level of hierarchy of
life so is it for Humanity
um that of course again it is a selfish
thing right I mean there's what would
happen if the if not a nuclear war let's
just say the Earth is hit by some
massive extinction level event that
wipes out Humanity well there there will
be other entities that will live and
it's not like all life would be
obliterated nor did it happen during the
Jurassic period when the giant
Extinction event took out all the
dinosaurs what happened then it allowed
mammals to thrive and flourish and then
we descended from that uh I'm not saying
I I want that to happen by the way don't
get me wrong uh but but the point is
when you put so much into uh this I mean
it's it's not I want to say it's a
fantasy but it is Escapist it's we are
escaping which is a good thing like if
you're on a plane going out and you
wanna you want that parachute that the
pessimist packed for you right
um on the other hand what's what's the
net goal it's it should be to preserve
Humanity right so would let's say it's
going to cost trillions and whatever
amount it is what if you could put that
into another thing that would alleviate
the need for Noah's Ark number two in
other words if Elon and put his time and
attention into putting in safeguards
against the main ways that a planet
could rid itself of our presence namely
nuclear war
um and some biological War uh or
biological entity like a virus that
becomes a global pandemic you know not
that that could ever happen
um so what could you do to to mitigate
those
um I think I think it's far more
efficient just just take one thing
um imagine you go down to uh to the
Pacific Ocean and you scoop up a bottle
of water you guys are invited come visit
me in my podcast in San Diego and we'll
go down to the beach and we'll scoop up
some water from the Civic there's
trillions of microorganisms in there
there's relics and fossils of Carl and
all sorts of things in there if you
found that on Mars it would be the
greatest discovery of all time
potentially right
um so but that means something very
different like that means you can find
life right now it's in the ocean and we
could could we live in the ocean well
maybe not like those guys unfortunately
in the submersible recently but you can
live and and we already know how to live
underwater
um you know there are people in the Navy
in San Diego that do it six months at a
time in the submarine right uh so so the
question is where is the most most
efficient use of resources intellectual
Capital human capital why is it why is
it that it's being focused in that
direction towards you know one planet
which is you know admittedly potentially
supportable of you know it's more
hospitable than Venus but but it's less
so than than the ocean do you know what
you're reminding me of there's a did you
ever watch West Wing uh no I never got
into that there's a great scene in West
Wing where the the the uh somebody asks
one of the staffers of the White House
why it is that we have to uh go to my I
think they're actually talking about
Mars and he launches into this long
monologue about how it's what's next as
in human beings have always explored
they've always taken the next step they
left the cave and they walked out and
then they went to the new world inverted
commas it's and it's kind of like the
idea is that we're an exploring species
right and and that's what's next and
what is that speak of though I think it
speaks of a restlessness and unhappiness
occurrences it's not like I want to oh I
really can't wait till I can get away
from my wife and kid yeah like if you're
happy and you and have a network of
connections a community uh something
that you have a deeper meaning for you
know Victor Frankl spoke about I'm sure
you guys have encountered this you know
that that as opposed to Freud who said
that you know the sexual drive was the
strongest innate Drive in humanity he
said no the search for meaning is and
people do anything for meaning including
deprive other people of their meaning
right uh and so
I think it is almost Escapist in a sense
and and I don't say that necessarily in
a judgmental way I'm just saying be
cognizant of it why are you doing what
you're doing and I've encountered that a
lot in in science as well uh but but one
thing I just want to come back to with
Mars
um and the search for alien life which
I'm very interested in yes
um although there I'm very pessimistic
about it as well and I think some of it
relates to these very same topics that
would cause somebody like a musk or
anybody who's conscious and and curious
about what it would be like to live on
another planet uh to think about what
are the planetary astrophysics based
limits to things like climate change
like is it possible that the climate
could just run away forever and we could
just keep pumping carbon dioxide into
this atmosphere well no it's not and in
fact by studying other EXO so-called
exoplanets of which we know of thousands
now many of which are exactly like the
Earth in terms of this host star that
they are orbiting around and and their
density and their average size so
there's plenty of places where life
could exist and so the question is well
what would it take for them to get to
the same stage that we had and I always
like to point out like I think you know
the key thing is the key question that I
would want to ask an alien is do you
have whales on your planet you're like
what the hell is he talking do they have
whales on your planet like why are you
asking about that well you know to get
here in this beautiful Studio to make
these beautiful Neon Lights the these
these computers that are driving the
cameras that are filming Us in glorious
4K right they weren't built by computers
right there wasn't like some some
primordial computer that sprung into I
don't know they were built up for
something more primitive uh and in fact
a computer was built up of transistors
and if you look at what a transistor is
the first one is this thing of like
chicken wire and chewing guy it was
really you wouldn't say like now there's
15 billion of them on my single iPhone
you know 14.
um but it's true and but it wasn't built
with an iPhone 14 right so you keep
going back and you come to like light
and you come to uh petroleum and so
forth so so whale oil was replaced by
petroleum so that means that for a long
time humans had their their lighting
needs met by instead of kerosene and
petroleum products by whale oil so like
well how they get how could they have
gotten there from point A to point B
yeah maybe they could have maybe they
could have discovered and they could
have but but the question is what are
the contingent things the things uh you
know the cinequan not without that it
makes the further justification of
Technology uh impossible right so we
look at things like plate tectonics
there are theories that suggest that the
biosphere that existed on Earth is
provided a lubricant that then allowed
the plates to move and and adjust
themselves from the Pangea configuration
into the more modern configuration over
a span of just a few millions of
hundreds of millions of years not a
short amount of time but not not as long
as they are all this here and some
people believe that's contingent that we
needed to have that in order to have
life exist
um so you start putting together all
these different
um uh sequences that had to occur and in
the right order right if you discovered
that how do you discover you know the
transistor before you had uh the vacuum
tube right is that possible maybe it is
maybe it's not so by asking questions
about these other planets we can then
learn about well what are the unique
things about our own planet and to just
go back to this discovery of Life thing
which I said you know uh I meant you
just go down to the lake and scoop up or
the Pacific Ocean scoop up some some
water
um we actually know what would happen
the day after life is discovered uh I
bet you guys think it would be pretty
exciting if we discovered did you know
that we discovered extraterrestrial life
on Earth or it was claimed that we did
this happen during the pandemic no well
it did uh yes yeah yes but also was
there like some fact dead bacteria on an
asteroid or something like that so yeah
I did read about it yeah so there's been
about eight different recordings of
acclaims of the discovery of
extraterrestrial life or technology
technology via a signal received from
another solar system potentially or a
byproduct of life in the case of what
was discovered during the pandemic as
Francis mentioned the so-called
byproduct of of living creatures called
phosphine was discovered on Venus it's
been been retracted uh there what I'm
talking about is uh from this very very
famous movie called contact with uh with
Jody Foster yeah so that was written by
Carl Sagan and his wife andrewian who
has been a guest on my podcast and uh
and it was the only science fiction book
he ever wrote and that book is based
Loosely on an actual figure it was
another guest named uh named Jill Tarter
who is a leader of the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence well in
the 19 1990s in Antarctica where I've
been twice they've discovered a
meteorite and that meteorites seemed to
have on it fragments or portions of
microorganisms either that or their
respiratory products in other words if
you found like you know exhale carbon
dioxide you have to ask how does it get
there because it doesn't form so easily
naturally pure oxygen doesn't form you
know so easily naturally so the question
how did it get there well so there was
this huge press conference and Bill
Clinton there's a scene in the movie
contact maybe you guys will cut it in
you guys have such a such an enormous
budget here
good afternoon
I'm glad to be joined by my
Science and Technology advisor
this is the product of years of
exploration
by some of the world's most
distinguished scientists
like all discoveries
this one will and should continue to be
reviewed examined and scrutinized
it must be confirmed by other scientists
if this discovery is confirmed it will
surely be one of the most stunning
insights into our universe that science
has ever uncovered its implications are
as far-reaching
and awe-inspiring as can be imagined
even as it promises answers to some of
our oldest questions it poses still
others even more fundamental we will
continue to listen closely to what it
has to say as we continue the search for
answers and for knowledge that is as old
as Humanity itself
but essential to our people's future
thank you
but he's on the way he's saying this
discovery if confirmed we go down as the
greatest discovery of all time okay so
it wasn't confirmed but it wasn't this
confirmed either for decades in other
words the general public was left and
that was a real scene now by the way
that was recorded and spliced into a
movie about the discovery you know in
this you know white albino guys it looks
weird and uh it's the whole Narrative of
the book that's fictional but that one
scene is factual
it goes to show you in the mind of the
general public that never was recanted
right you you but you guys just both
mentioned two separate claims of it so
did those change the world they didn't
change I mean did you guys wake up and
say oh well like all all's restored now
I have meaning in my life because they
discovered some phosphine on Venus and
for us all you know they didn't
disconfirm it right I just told you that
they it hasn't been confirmed some
people most people don't believe it's
it's valid so it didn't change your
lives so why do we think you know
discovering life on another planet or
going to another planet is going to find
this Transcendent meaning I I find that
it's it's not entirely self-consistent
and so so but isn't it also about
pushing the limits of what we think
human beings can do isn't isn't that it
seeing a self-imposed limit then going
beyond that isn't that consistent with
the with the human Spirit the drive from
all the the wanting to test yourself
push beyond the limits of society or
what people think human beings okay
capable of so I'm going to give you one
example from from my country and one
example from your country so 112 years
ago there was a race every bit as
viscerally competitive as the Space Race
to land on the moon which I'll get to
next yeah and that was the race to reach
the South Pole in park which as I said
I've been there twice uh it's as close
to the most boring uh undeveloped you
know Pure White hellscape of a frozen
planet in any science fiction movie
you've ever seen you go out there here's
how you picture it go in the middle of
the Atlantic Ocean flash freeze it solid
and then look around you what would you
see it's nothing for 700 miles and yeah
that was the goal of a generation of
explorers dating back to Raul damenson
and Robert Falcon Scott and they both
approached it amundson actually tried to
reach the North Pole first failed
immediately did a 180 literal 180 and he
beat Scott to the South Pole uh by three
weeks and that's three-week period
between December when he reached in
January when Scott reached it meant the
difference between life and death for
the explorers in Scott's party and the
reason they did that there's many
reasons why the Brits were doing it on a
scientific Journey so they were trying
to they would encounter things for the
Royal geographical Society they pick up
a meteorite they would find meteorites
there too they found you know petrified
seals and but mostly it was pretty much
boring ski trip the other thing is that
the Norwegians were very comfortable
using animals as their Rockets you know
as their exploration Vehicles driving
them uh knowing full well that once you
got to the top of the South Pole or
Plateau it's about nine thousand feet
above sea level which most people don't
realize pretty high up so they had to
ski up over these dangerous things
called crevasses the people dying and
freeze to death and so they escape the
dogs would pull them up and then the way
home they don't need the dogs so what do
you think they had you know for lunch at
the top of the world or bottom of the
world they would eat the dogs the Brits
didn't want to do that so they had to be
their own conveyance animals and they
pulled their sleds which meant they had
to carry more food more fuel more
everything so it ended up costing them
between life and death that
technological decision that they made
which there are some parallels here so
this was reached at Great cost it was a
huge thing people and you know probably
about the Shackleton voyages these
captivated the world I mean these were
some of the most interesting things they
far Horizon go what's over it
um do you know that we didn't go back to
Antarctica for over 50 years
like in other words they reach this goal
they got there and then they left and
they didn't come back for 50 years and
now there's about a hundred people there
in the middle we're talking in the
middle of the northern hemisphere summer
exactly it's the middle of winter at the
South Pole there's about 45 people
that's it for 700 miles you can be like
the richest person on the continent the
fattest person on the god you could be
whatever you want on a continent the
size of Western United States it's huge
right
um then now let's fast forward another
you know 50-year interval which we
haven't gone back to at least we've gone
back to the South Pole that's the
exploration of the Moon first reach 1969
July 20th when we got there it said we
came in peace For All Mankind really it
was a Battle of Cold War superiority it
was a it was an intellect but in other
words people always talk about the need
for human exploration but really when we
point to it we're really thinking about
a psychological Frontier more than like
a physical Frontier otherwise why
wouldn't we have gone back to the Moon
if it was so beneficial you know there's
helium-3 there and there's you know
there's a lot of uh you know minerals
aluminum whatever maybe not enough to
overcome that kind of what I call the
Roger banister Pro so once Roger
Bannister broke the four minute mile you
know it became past nobody was really
that interested oh I'm going to be 357
who cares canister already did that so
there's this first kind of priority and
actually what Scott said resonates
through to this day he said great God
when he reached the South Pole imagine
you're coming you know out of the lunar
lander and and Neil Armstrong steps onto
a Soviet Union Flag okay
the SE guys had that experience they
were skiing and from the South Pole so
flat and so Barren they could see the
Norwegian flag from miles away so they
got there they knew that they had lost
and they still had to make it there to
say that they had reached the South Pole
at least as maybe check maybe he was off
by a couple feet no he wasn't skylinson
was quite awesome and navigation as well
he got there he saw it he said great God
said Scott this is an awful place
all the more so for having reached it
without the benefit of priority
that's the human drive we want to get
there first it's not getting there
getting there so if it was getting there
we would have set up a compound and done
all this cool stuff same on the moon
we haven't gone back there I predict the
same on my I think we can get to Mars I
think a person can get there I think
establishing an output is is almost as
uh remote or impossible as establishing
one on the Moon yes I know Zuber and
you'll write in and say that yeah
there's more raw materials there there's
a lot of raw materials in Antarctica I
don't see any civilizations popping up
down there and if you say well like
there's this fallacy that if there was a
nuclear war and God forbid there's ever
a nuclear war I'm not I'm not advocating
again
no not at all I treasure this planet and
in fact I'm trying to say we should be
dedicating our efforts towards the
mitigation the meditation against the
destruction of the planet but these
idiots who have been given so I always
say the worst thing about physics is
that it produces technology the worst
thing is that we saved the world right
we created the atomic bomb there's a
movie coming out it's the summer
Oppenheimer one of my friends shua Peck
is an amazing human being he's a star
and not not the main character but he's
one of the stars and I'm gonna chat with
him on the podcast soon
um we we saved the world using physics
using the laws of physics nuclear
nuclear fission creating an atomic
device we then had the that would not
end even human life on Earth it might
not be so great but if musk or others I
don't want to single them out by the way
uh because I think it's a very you know
you know generous and interesting thing
that he's trying to do if misguided in
terms of his ultimate aim because we
could establish a human Outpost in
Antarctica that could happen there's way
more resources it's incredible to make
one kilogram to take this coffee cup
into space he's reduced it from ten
thousand dollars to a few hundred
dollars it's still you know uh 80 to 100
times more expensive than doing the same
thing which I can get Frappuccino down
at the South Pole anytime I want soft
serve on on demand it's incredible so
you know we have to question is that the
most efficient way to accomplish the
goal of archiving and backing up into
the cloud what human consciousness is so
your point is
it's a misallocation of resources in my
opinion
hey KK do you like trigonometry of
course I do incredible interviews
fascinating guests phenomenal live shows
and hilarious raw streams in that case
you need to join our locals so you can
have access to even more brilliant
content that's right you get the chance
to win incredible prizes ask our
phenomenal guests your questions access
extra content and now the only place to
watch our Roars on catch-up is on locals
are War shows still go out at 7 pm UK
time 2 p.m Eastern as normal but if you
want to watch some after this time then
you're gonna need to sign up to our
locals Ross have now become too spicy to
stay on YouTube so they're only
available to watch back on our locals
page all you need to do to sign up is
click on the link below this video and
for just seven dollars a month you have
access to All of This brilliant content
seven dollars a month even for someone
of my persuasion that's a bargain see
fuel on locals
and what should we be focusing on I
think the most important thing is
education I think the more stem educated
people we are with a balance of as I
said the humanities in this in the in
the kind of model of a Galileo in the
model of a Newton or any of the great
you know
um champions of science scientific
tradition foreign
if you can couple that with a sense of I
don't want to say Divine because I think
it has a lot of religious overtones I
happen to be practicing uh Jew in my
case but but in the sense of that you
have to recognize the limitations of the
human ability but that that's like an
innervating A positive thing that you
should say look we are here for this
brief brief amount of time it is a flash
of the eye how do we then inculcate our
children our civilization with meaning
science is great for producing
technology and so we come to expect
technology from basic science
um and that's fine if you can have a
steward of that technology that is
competent capable Soulful and disposed
towards the same types of goals that
someone like a musker or others are
concerned with the preservation of what
is unique and treasured and beautiful
about about human human beings which I
think is our soul our Consciousness
depending on how you phrase it so I
think education in particular in the
stem Fields I think that will become
more and more important and harder and
harder to replace by artificial
intelligence as well I think the
pandemic showed us that I think the
pandemic what the pandemic showed is and
this rapidly became clear to me as well
is our own ignorance and I include
myself in this when it comes to science
and medicine and all of these things so
you just realize that people who were
very intelligent
they have no idea how to analyze or how
to talk about these subjects without
becoming overly emotional and making
choices that were for quite frankly
ridiculous in many cases even even the
most educated in some cases I mean
there's a famous quote by one of my
heroes Richard Feynman he said science
is the belief in the ignorance of
experts not the wisdom not the knowledge
of expert but the ignorance of it what
the hell are you talking about fireman
was a genius Einstein was a genius yeah
they were genius B because they outed
what came before them science has never
settled you never say oh well this
vaccine's 100 effective it's going to
prevent transmission it's going to cure
you it's going to no no scientist was
really okay I shouldn't say none because
a lot of good scientists did that a lot
of scientists were behind behind it I
got vaccinated you know even I didn't
have my kids didn't get vaccinated I'm
glad that they didn't we still have a
vaccine requirement in my University to
attend it in 2023 in the fall of 2023 we
still have to be vaccinated and it's
incredible to me
um and I taught for a long time wearing
a paper mask that I could take off if I
had a sip of my my trusty vodka that I
kept with me at all the time uh so so we
became very highly leveraged on science
as a replacement for God yes that's so
powerful yeah I mean you were required
to have faith exactly in the science the
science yeah follow the science no I
don't trust that I don't have faith you
know in Hebrew the word amen which we
get in English as well means Faith or
truth belief I believe I always say I
don't believe in gravity I don't believe
in it I have evidence for Gravity I
don't believe in evolution we have
evidence for evolution why you asked me
to believe and follow and trust and say
this person represents sign no scientist
says that no valid scientist says that
it's doing something political I always
say the problem with you know with with
political science is that's not limited
to just political scientists
I feel and this is controversial I don't
think I've said this elsewhere but I
think that oftentimes scientists realize
we've been given this glorious script
the the book of nature you know as uh
Galileo said is written in the language
of mathematics right uh it's this
beautiful script and yet we're so clumsy
at communicating it because we're never
taught those soft disciplines of the
second culture of the CP snow spoke
about how do you communicate uh now I
start doing this with my students it's
not enough that they're they're Way
Beyond me math physics they understand
so much they're so quick they're so
they're so uh there's there's just so
impressive my students uh and and that's
the goal you should always exceed you
know Leonardo da Vinci said poor is a
student who doesn't exceed the master
um and so the notion of what is science
in terms of the word science from Latin
means knowledge doesn't mean wisdom
that's Sapien that's where we get Homo
Sapien what does it mean homo sapi means
man who knows
man who was why what is he wise about do
you ever think about this your dog
doesn't know he's gonna die
your pet cat doesn't know she's gonna
die
humans the only species that know that
our time is limited that's what we know
about now where does that come from that
comes from the Bible we ate from the
Tree of knowledge of life and death of
Good and Evil uh okay you can take it as
an allegory but but the point being we
have put so much faith in science
because it's so powerful because it
produces this glorious technology that
allowed us to communicate and set this
up at the speed of light across
continents that are planetary and scale
that we then demand it and then we say I
don't understand this just like I don't
understand God uh you know if you're
religious so you tend to correlate
associate a godliness with science but
there's nothing science is amoral it's
not immoral it's amoral look at the most
advanced civilization scientifically of
the past Century where was it far from
yours in Germany Germany
um I went to the Imperial War Museum the
other day with my children
I I couldn't believe the horrors that
you see there and and the equivalent of
what they had back then
um
technologically it was so sophisticated
some of the greatest scientists in
history
worked fresh and others worked on the
what was later become known as the Haber
Bosch process and um and Fritz Haber was
a German Jew in the early 1900s and he
was very patriotic he wanted to be
basically fully assimilated into German
Society he was known as a father
chemical warfare he invented chlorine
gas which then his Factory then became
the main production vehicle for zyklon B
which was used in the concentration
camps they killed his own family members
years later
so never conflate knowledge with wisdom
and but that's that's the heart that you
need wisdom to see who is wise
and and you know as talmud says Thomas
says who is a wise person someone who
learns from every person they meet okay
you don't want to be like well my
three-year-old can teach me as much as
you know Professor Keating uh but uh but
at the same time wisdom can only be
acquired by experience and when you
encounter something that's never
happened before like a pandemic or
nuclear potential conflict
um it's very dicey to put so much power
in the hands of someone who may not be
particularly wise and do you sometimes
find that in your own industry that
people think that they have the answers
they think they're all knowing and
all-powerful when the reality is you're
a scientist and you could be brilliant
but that doesn't stop you from being
wrong oh yeah some of those so and I've
had the benefit to interview 14 Nobel
Prize winners on my podcast it's kind of
become one of my trademarks on the into
the impossible podcast and um and I
always like to end it though that you
guys have your wonderful question which
we'll get to in a couple hours
and uh and I always ask you know similar
questions but from taken from uh more
perspective of of almost like a
scrapping meaning to a scientist so most
scientists don't aren't comfortable
talking about you know big picture
things uh we're not particularly
outgoing you know there's all joke how
do you know a scientist is outgoing
he looks at your shoes when he talks to
you you know then that's how you can
spot him uh but but the point being we
we don't communicate these things to our
students so they're left with this
notion that like while Einstein was
always Einstein no he wasn't he was very
fallible uh fine and I just gave you
that quote right the ignorance of
experts not the wisdom of experts
um so the best scientists were are aware
of this and in fact I encountered this
when I interviewed a man who's become a
good friend of mine a mentor his name is
Barry barish he won the 2017 Nobel prize
for the discovery of gravitational waves
so two black holes 1.2 billion light
years away from the earth crashed
together in This Dance of Death that
happened 1.2 billion years ago and these
reverberations in space and time rippled
throughout the cosmos and percolated
throughout the Universe we don't
actually know which Galaxy it was in
eventually it hit the Milky Way galaxy
entered into our solar system entered
into our planet and then hit two
different detectors one in in Louisiana
and one in Washington state within a few
minutes seconds of each other consistent
with Einstein's laws of Relativity and
he detected this reverberation in space
and time and I asked him after he won
the Nobel Prize he was on my podcast and
I said uh my my closing quote is about
the the name of the podcast comes from
Arthur C Clarke he said the only way of
determining the limits of the possible
is to go beyond them into the impossible
so I always ask my analog of you know
what are we not asking is um what would
you tell your 20 year old self you know
what would you tell him or her to give
you the courage to do as you've done to
go into the impossible and he would say
um over you have to overcome the
Imposter syndrome
um especially you know after you win the
Nobel Prize I said what the hell are you
talking wait you won the Nobel Prize and
you have the Imposter syndrome he goes
oh yeah winning the Nobel Prize made it
worse
it's like Barry come on you're one of
the most brilliant human beings that
ever lived like you're telling me you
have the Imposter syndrome what hope is
there for anybody else he said well when
you win a Nobel Prize you go to
Stockholm you meet the king you eat some
reindeer and you have this fetid
celebration and one of the things they
do before they give you this you know
giant Flavor Flav Medallion and uh they
give you a check for your share of the
one million dollar purse uh is you sign
a log book a log book a test the fact
that you received your medallion your
check and your hand-painted plaque so
they want to make sure you don't come uh
where's that uh November because it's
you know 24 karat gold plated right so
they don't have many of them so he said
he's a curious sort so he looked at The
Ledger and they have the original Ledger
going back to shortly after Alfred Nobel
died in in 1896
um and the first one was award in 1901.
so he looks back through the pages and
he sees Richard Feynman you know pretty
amazing he sees Marie Curie and he stops
he sees Einstein
and he goes my heart stopped
I said why he said well you see Einstein
and me a couple of pages apart and our
signatures are there I'm not worthy
I said Barry I've got good news and good
news for you I said Barry do you know
that Einstein had the Imposter syndrome
he goes oh really uh and I said yeah
yeah he had the Imposter syndrome really
bad in fact and I said well and he asked
me who did he have the Imposter syndrome
about and he said I told him Isaac
Newton he called Isaac Newton not only
the greatest mathematician and physicist
of all time but the greatest contributor
to human civilization that ever lived
and I said but wait there's more I said
Newton had the Imposter syndrome as well
you guys know who Newton worshiped the
way that Einstein worshiped Newton one
of the Greeks maybe oh no no oh I was
going to say something like our comedies
but no no Jesus Christ
do you know what he called his greatest
accomplishment possibly apocryphally
hard to verify this he died a virgin
because that was the only way that he
could emulate Christ
he was very religious extremely devout
religious man so he felt that he was
inadequate an imposter before the likes
of Jesus Christ okay that's pretty good
company to feel that about but this that
this is a human trait is a very good
thing and I want to bring this back
because you asked me that scientists
have this notion of kind of superiority
when maybe it's unearned in other words
maybe they're spending kind of The
credibility that the great Titans liked
Feynman like the Einsteins who did
grapple with I mean Einstein is way more
written about his thoughts on being
you know on Politics on nationalism on
Zionism you know they asked him to be
one of the first presidents of Israel
and he could have he could have had a
good career if he like just imagine the
fame he could have had a fee uh
so so he has way more writing I'd rather
be a physicist yeah he's less stressful
so he has a way more written word about
his um his thoughts on on God and
culture than he does about physics by
far same with Feynman but but the point
being uh they married these two traits
of humility with swagger and that's very
hard again there's an ambiguity it's
like we said before it's easy to follow
the left or the right it's hard to be in
the middle yeah so they could be humble
to say as much as I learn the the battle
will be infinite will never end science
like you never win science you can win a
Nobel Prize you can get tenure you can
get into a good college graduate school
you can't win science there's no end to
it it's an infinite game as I say but on
the other hand you have to also have a
little bit of confidence Swagger that
look what you know who is a man that
they can take on the challenge of
unraveling the tapestry of Nature and
the best scientists have that you do you
want to say your girlfriend I was going
to say because one thing that you've
been very interesting about when and
when I read your work you've actually
written a book about this is actually
being very critical of the Nobel Prize
and you just brought the Nobel Prize up
now to an uneducated simpleton like me I
think what the Nobel Prize that's the
greatest achievement possibly a human
being could ever have well what's wrong
with a Nobel Prize right yeah there's
there's a lot wrong with it and there's
a lot right with it and like anything
again we wrestle with ambiguities there
are people that believe uh that abortion
should be completely you've had on Ben
Shapiro you said that right here he said
no abortion okay then there have been
people that you've had on
um talked about population yeah whatever
and they'll say nope you should it's a
woman's choice you can do whatever she
wants so uh those are two polls people
cleave to the two poles hard to be in
the middle and say well you know I want
to have this it's like Schrodinger's cat
it's Is it alive or is it dead well I
understand when it's alive I understand
when it's dead what is this thing where
it's alive and dead at the same time
this mind-bending notion from quantum
mechanics um that we'll get into for the
the locals get the homework assignments
we give them they uh the quantum
mechanics somewhere
um so so the good so is the uh Nobel
Prize good or bad yes it has good things
it has things that are worthy of of
retaining it has things that distort and
um and in some cases destroy how science
is done by putting it into uh again this
conflation between knowledge and wisdom
every four years in America the New York
Times publishes an article which says
signed by 70 Nobel Prize winners why you
should vote for the present the Democrat
who's running for president never once
have these 70 Nobel Prize winners ever
endorsed the Republican be that as it
may they're always right but then
they'll talk about like genetically
modified organisms they talked about
funding for Peter dashik at the Eco
Health Alliance chance they supported it
that he that when Trump tried to suspend
the 70 Nobel Prize winners come out and
do that they're using this clout they're
using their that what they've earned
rightfully so by their grappling and
wrestling with major ideas and Science
and solving unknown things and being
smarter than I could ever aspire to be
but they're using that to opine in
political space that's a danger right
because you're now outside of your lane
completely they have a right to do it
not saying they shouldn't speak about it
but someone who studies the cosmos what
do they know about a treaty with Iran
what do they know about you know what
the abortion policy they might they're
entitled to it doesn't mean they know it
what the Nobel Prize does is it becomes
a secular Idol uh that literally as
Barry confirmed to me you bow down in
front of the king of Sweden wearing
Royal regalia that's required and you
bow down and you accept a gilded Graven
image with the Visage of Alfred Nobel on
it uh so like every religion it has an
origin story it has patron saints it has
apostates
and so it has become a secular religion
and and sometimes the most zealous
religious adherents are atheist
93 of the American National Academy of
Sciences do not actively affirm a belief
in God
I'm not saying you know you should you
shouldn't I'm not a theocrat right but
um but it's an interesting fact and
almost in every case
the Nobel Prize spans these divides
between what uh what you know uh Rabbi
uh Salvation used to call uh the the
resume virtues uh versus the eulogy
virtues so the notion is that uh you
should you have things that you'll put
on your your gravestone or you have read
about you father son brother you know
whatever scientist uh and then there'll
be you resume I went to Brown University
Case Western I got my PhD in the title
you see like I'm not gonna No One's
Gonna talk about that you know hopefully
when I'm 120 and pass away but
where was he an undergraduate like let
me put that on the tombstone no there's
only so much space so I think you know
we but the Nobel Prize will always be
there there's never been a a eulogy or
something where it's not mentioned for
somebody right so so the question
becomes you know what is it doing to
culture how does it distort the way that
science is done funding for science
you're much more likely to get something
if it's in a field where someone's won a
Nobel Prize if your advisor won a Nobel
Prize you're much more likely to win it
um there's historic discrimination that
was present early on against Jews later
against women and other minorities
that's been uh that's been dimensionally
proven
um so it's good and bad do I want it
destroyed no that's why I wrote the book
people get this notion that oh I wrote
the book called losing the Nobel Prize
because I was uh I was jealous and
spurned and the sour grapes that I
didn't win the Nobel Prize for this
discovery that I played a huge role in
that was announced and later retracted
in 2014 and 2015. that would have been
Nobel worthy had we not been stymied by
another Galactic imposter that
masqueraded as a signal we were trying
to see which was the spark of the
universe's first existing moments but in
reality so they'll say oh you're just
half sour grapes Keating you're just you
know from I say well look here's the one
way to prove it good news for you you
can prove if I'm a hypocrite or not get
them to offer me the Nobel Prize if I
accept it I'm a hypocrite so far they
haven't bitten but but the point being
I've seen it from the inside I've been
asked multiple times to nominate winners
of the Nobel Prize I've compared it to
what Alfred Nobel requested in his will
and how it's been distorted for purposes
of the vainglory of the Nobel Prize
committee and its and its own purposes
and to the destruction of scientific
colleagues of mine uh and Distortion of
the scientific method in fact so it's
good and bad right come back to the
science with me uh because this is the
really fascinating thing so we've talked
a little bit about it but I think the
two big questions that most people have
about
space the universe Etc is are we alone
and the conversation that Eric is very
much fond of which is chemistry is
imposes very specific limitations on our
ability to get anywhere in the universe
and physics potentially
is able to transcend those so
um are we ever going to be able to to
travel in a way that doesn't require us
to essentially burn lots of fuel and
travel in a linear way right first of
all yeah so yeah I agree with you those
are two interesting the other one I
always get asked about is you know what
happened before the universe came into
it right
yeah so that's that's what I get uh paid
you know big dollars from Gavin Newsom
to answer
uh so so to answer the the second
question that you answered so can we
transcend the limits uh can we
effectively you know uh create a portal
to
allow us to travel in finite time
essentially infinite distances there's
nothing that precludes that from
happening but it's been so trumpeted in
things like movies Interstellar you know
all these things uh the notion of
wormholes and black holes and physicists
Associated obsessed with holes come on
guys uh get over yourselves but uh but
the point being if you could essentially
visualize space time we can't visualize
actual space-time as four-dimensional
that means there's three dimensions up
down right left backwards forwards
um we can visualize that plus time
that's four dimensions if I tell you I
want to meet you in Trafalgar you say
Trafalgar or Trafalgar Trafalgar Square
at exactly 4 P.M you know where when and
it's up to you how you get there the
question is can I fold space time you
know basically take it like a piece of
paper so we can be out here at the at
the trigonometry uh podcast you know
compound and fold it so that it would
essentially take no time because because
those two place is in space-time in a
higher dimensional space so to do that
you have to fold it into another
dimension right you have to fold it from
the two-dimensional analogy into into
the third dimension put them next to
each other the question is that possible
all we can say is there's nothing that
precludes that from happening we have no
evidence that that's even possible so
the theories that Eric and others have
worked on rely on things of having
multiple extra Dimensions more than four
less than 20 and that may seem like well
you know who cares less enough out those
can be very well rationalized why it's
say 10 or 11 uh in Eric's Theory versus
say four that we observed today but I
should say there's no evidence for it so
the first thing then what I like to talk
about when when I'm with Eric is what
are some of the ways that we could
verify not the actual existence of
either strings or the subatomic you know
microscope Atomic level or extra
dimensions on a grander scale and his
and his model of geometric Unity but are
there testable traces vestigial relics
of those models that can be tested at
the relatively low energies that we have
accessible on Earth or at the most
powerful Cosmic accelerator of all which
was the Big Bang which is what I study
so there will be relics just like right
now
in this glass of finest vodka there are
molecules of hydrogen and oxygen the
hydrogen in here came from The Big Bang
this is an artifact of the big bang that
I'm holding right now in your body there
are artifacts of the Big Bang the oxygen
came much later from a generation of
stars that very you know um a very
almost scatologically sacrificed
themselves blew up became and their
byproducts became the oxygen in here but
that's basically it right
um so there are relics that have
traveled through time and we can study
the composition of this and ask actually
in here if we zoom in real tight and I
know your crack animation team will do
this to justice that I can only dream of
but if you zoom in every so often about
one in a few million particles of of
water in here molecules of water have a
hydrogen molecule that has an extra
Neutron so you guys know because this is
the one of the second most erudite
podcast in all existence after my
podcast uh that hydrogen has three
isotopes that means they have two
different numbers of neutrons so there's
a hydrogen which is a proton then
there's a proton plus a neutron that's
called deuterium then there's a proton
plus two neutrons otherwise they're
chemically identical you can drink it I
have videos on my channel where I make
it into ice and I drink it this glass
has a ratio of tritium and deuterium and
ordinary protonic water that is exactly
predicted in the theory of cosmology
known as The Big Bang nucleosynthesis so
that is a vestigial relationship but
just in this glass of water we could go
in the laboratory next door and measure
it that means we can prove the Big Bang
can we do the same for string theory can
we do the same for what's called Loop
quantum gravity can't wait to do the
same for Stephen wolfram's uh physics
project Eric Weinstein's geometric Unity
can we do that are there any first we
have to answer those questions so yes
we're a long way off from from
motivating it it is nice to think about
the most concrete thing we can say is
there's nothing that forbids it but is
there any evidence for it that's not
something and it sounds like Elon says
so far there isn't there isn't and
there's definitely no evidence for it
but there's also no evidence for string
theory as Eric talked about and that's
garnered a lot more attention time and
money all right are we alone in the
universe I've always been persuaded by
the pure statistical argument that given
the scale of it there's bound to be and
you mentioned yourself you talked about
there's loads of planets and the
Goldilocks on uh all around the universe
surely there's intelligent life
somewhere out there right statistically
speaking right so so that I like to make
the the following analogy so I believe
that there's no intelligent life in the
universe
I mean especially on this planet yeah
that's right this this planet's uh the
worst except for all the others yeah
um so uh I believe that we've become
very uh enamored of this notion again
there is some primordial Beauty to the
notion of escaping and thinking about
things that transcend our limitations of
time or space or existence and one of
those is the existence of other life
forms that may exist in in the universe
first of all we can say there's zero
evidence for such life forms even a
slime mold on Enceladus you know in our
own solar system there's no evidence for
it and that's important because uh there
is a concept purported by by the man who
coined the term Big Bang actually you
guys are the perfect people asses I've
never gotten a straight answer is Big
Bang a dirty word is it a dirty phrase
no no no because supposedly Hoyle Fred
Hoyle sir Fred Hoyle is one of the
greatest astronomers in history he
coined the term Big Bang as a pejorative
meaning orgasm ah so that's never said
in this country we had a better sex life
uh no I didn't know that no I don't
think nobody would do it so he was he
was a proponent of the steady state
model uh but but in any case he uh the
he also came up with the notion of
what's called panspermia can I say that
on the show yeah whatever you want it's
a free speech it's a free speech on
great so the notion of what's called
panspermia it means that uh that there
will be exchange of material between
planets and between other star systems
in our galaxy and that will potentially
uh be a an almost like a Noah's Ark for
life to transport it doesn't solve the
origin of life problems but it could
potentially solve the uh abundance of
Life problem in our solar system or how
how did it come here he claimed could
have come from another another planet uh
not too far away by Cosmic standards so
it gets here now I actually have some of
this and as we said there's meteorites
and so forth there are found in
Antarctica it's well known phenomenon I
actually have a tiny piece of Mars it
doesn't have any amino acids or DNA or a
little uh green met on it but its games
comes from Mars and we can prove it
comes from Mars uh just trust me we have
it from many other bodies in our solar
system so why is that important that
means that things can come here well
guess what that means that things can go
from the earth out there right so you
have to answer the question what is the
probability and what does it say about
life in the universe that we haven't
found life say on Mars now Mars a big
place and yeah if we went somewhere on
Earth but almost everywhere on Earth has
life almost everywhere even Antarctica
where I've been Antarctica is
one-seventh of the total number of
continents on this planet it's about the
size of Australia uh so it's pretty it's
pretty big there's almost no life there
though there's almost no there is life
there's microbial life there are these
giant birds called skuas uh that will
like take a toddler away if the toddlers
were allowed on the content notes or not
um and then there's sea lions a couple
Penguins on the coast that's about it
there's no polar bears or anything like
that
um and then there's humans so you're
talking about you know this vast
continent the size of Australia hundreds
of times you know tens of times bigger
than the UK
no life almost no life but if you make
the argument that life should be
abundant or based on statistical
probability as Fermi did Enrico Fermi
one of the greatest physicists he
created What's called the Fermi Paradox
there's so many planets there's so many
gold they didn't know about the
Goldilocks zone back then but they said
if uh if the average lifetime of a
technological civilization is even a
million years then just in the age of
our galaxy which is which is maybe eight
billion years or more uh that means we
should have been visited by thousands in
that even going at a slow chemical
rocket speed so he asked the famous
question where are they so we have to
ask where are they and and come up with
solutions to that Fermi Paradox and
there are many purported solutions but
one of which is there are no aliens
right I mean the most simple thing based
on evidence is that there are no
certainly technological civilizations
that we're aware of that could be beyond
what we're uh where now the best
calculations do the following they don't
say and as I don't say I don't say
there's no life I say the probability is
very small uh and certainly even smaller
for technological life it has to be even
smaller right if there's a dolphin
swimming on a pool and Enceladus we're
never going to know about it because it
doesn't have an iPhone to let us know
that we live there unless we stumble
upon it right so it has to be
technological how do we get to that
technology comes back to what we said
before we started with primitive things
maybe our hydrocarbons necessary is
global warming a trademark a Hallmark of
civilization some say it is in other
words we should look not for uh
Transmissions of you know I Love Lucy
but we should look for global warming on
another planet so far we haven't seen it
doesn't mean it doesn't exist but that
would mean terraforming and modifying
the the that particular client then did
they have a biosphere
did they have chlorophyll do they have a
great oxidation event did they have a
Jupiter that sucks up deadly asteroids
from impacting the the Earth or whatever
the analog Earth is in the Goldilocks
zone that's not in the Goldilocks zone
do they have a moon that's at the exact
right distance to create tides that can
cause chemical intubation almost between
uh life Land and Sea do they have plate
tectonics that we talked about are those
plate tectonics lubricated by these
microorganisms so there's many different
hurdles and the way I like to say it is
so you can phrase it like this imagine
that there were eight things that had to
happen for us to have this conversation
under these Lights and Camera right that
had to be a big bang you know there had
to be the formation of matter from no
matter so people think that a matter is
conserved it's not energy is conserved
but matters now then there had to be
primitive elements that could support
life then life had to come about be
conscious then that life that was
conscious how to create technology and
so forth so you just go through and you
say it like this and then there had to
be things that prevented it asteroids
are going to be dinosaurs that got that
were there but got killed off and
fossils and so you didn't say there's
eight of them and each one has a
probability of one in a thousand that's
it just say one in a thousand that
there's a big bang whatever that means
one of the Thousand that there's a
Jupiter one thousand and we know the
probabilities are much much much much
lower let's just say for the sake of the
argument one divided by a thousand eight
of those you take one over a thousand
you raise it to the eighth power you get
one in 10 to the 24th that same number
is the inverse of the number of planets
we think there are in the observable
universe's history so over 13.8 billion
years we think there have been 10 to the
24th which is a trillion trillion
planets that could be life inhabiting
but the probability I just said is one
in 10 to the 24th so that so the problem
comes about the human mind is incapable
of multiplying a zero by an infinity and
that's why the statistical argument I
think is a very crude but often
overestimate of the probability of
possibility of technology so
the emergence of life on Earth is so
ridiculously unlikely that's right that
for that to be replicated anywhere in
the universe even with the number of
planets that exist is still
extraordinarily unlikely because it was
so unlikely that it was formed here yeah
and there's so many contingent things
that have to occur it's just the right
order which brings us inexorably to the
final question of the three that you
always get asked yeah which is about
where life comes from yeah so I think
where everything comes from where
everything comes from yeah so
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
so right now is an interesting time
because throughout history you know if
you took a a ping pong ball and you put
it in a bag for each year that human
civilization has existed uh say going
back 5 000 years uh the very first
cosmological models in the Bible in
ancient Egypt and Samaria and you wrote
on it what's your model of the universe
like is it Eternal is it cyclical is
there a turtle on top of a turtle is
there a Burros eating its tail what is
it just just put it in there the
overwhelming number of ping pong balls
would have a static Eternal Universe
Einstein believed in it Newton believed
in it it's interesting the Bible does
not believe in it the Bible has a
creation event right uh there are
Egyptian myths that have a creation but
most models most people for all time
believed that the Universe was static
and in fact the name that we get static
meaning it exists has always existed and
will always exist as it is exactly right
100 right so uh and why do we know that
well we're sitting on this thing called
a planet I don't know if you know any
Greek my Greek's not that strong but
Planet means Wanderer well why do we
have a name it's like Jews we talk about
people that aren't Jewish we call them
goyam or we you know it just means
Nation it's not like a put down or
anything
um but that's interesting because like
we're only 0.2 percent of the population
of the world right so we're saying we
have a name for the 99 like I just call
them people and like we're the weird
ones right but but anyway uh so we have
a name for these things that moved
they're called planets well why were
they special because they were the only
things that moved everything else is
static it looks like it's unchanging we
know the stars move a little bit but you
couldn't perceive them over human
lifetime but the five planets that they
could see back then after which our days
are named and so forth there's deep
inculcation of astronomy in our daily
lives we just take for granted but but
anyway
um those things move and so it was
natural to suspect as Newton did as
Einstein did that the Universe was
static and eternal uh and that prevailed
for an extremely long period the
preponderance of human history and so we
asked the question of what could
overthrow that well before I would say
the last decade it was impossible to
speculate any more than just purely
qualitatively but now with telescopes
and tools like that of my team uh that
my team and I are working on called the
Simon's Observatory and other competitor
teams we're looking potentially at a
relic just like these water molecules
reveal the fiery Fusion conditions that
were present in the first second after
the big bang we're able to go 30 orders
of magnitude farther back in time
and we will reveal the presence via what
are called gravitational waves those
gravitational waves would originate from
a Quantum a purely Quantum phase of the
universe's history called inflation okay
what does any of that mean okay so the
universe the question is did the
universe come from what's called The
Singularity or not was there a point of
infinite temperature infinite density
infinite energy from which all the
matter and energy that we're
experiencing today came from including
the molecules in here including every
cell in our body the matter of that so
forgive me I'm just trying to make it
simple enough that it is like me can
understand hopefully other people
watching can understand as well so the
idea of the Big Bang is you have this
matter that is
I'm I'm using very stupid language I'm
aware but it's super condensed
absolutely and then it explodes and
cools over time and that's how you get
the universe exactly so it's either that
yeah or or a static Universe there are
actually other or more than one other
alternative yeah it could be that there
was a preceding universe that had a big
bang in Reverse called a big crunch it
could be that there are multiple
universes that exist parallel to ours of
which we're just one that has properties
features and phenomena consistent with
the existence of cosmologists and
podcasts and people right so we want to
know is our universe an accident yeah is
it a fluctuation a fluke and using
technology for the first time we can
confirm that we could potentially reveal
that our universe did in fact begin not
only with the singularity with a point
of incomprehensible hellscape like
energy density pressure everything you
could imagine
but it would also reveal the presence of
what's called a Multiverse
just as Copernicus and Galileo showed
that the Earth is just a planet it's not
the center of the universe as people
have thought for thousands of years now
back to Aristotle and beyond that the
Universe was centered on the earth
because that was a natural place for it
to be no they disproved that they
conjectured in the case of Copernicus
and proved in the sense of Galileo and
eventually Isaac Newton no but there's
more than one planet there's more than
one star there's more than one Galaxy
there's more than one cluster there's
more than one supercluster of galaxies
why not more than one universe and in
fact can comatant with the singular
origin of the universe
comes the Multiverse so in other words
you almost cannot have a single
Singularity a big bang without having a
Multiverse they're almost wedded at the
hip so the stakes are very high because
that's very in you know it's very
incompatible with say biblical
narratives or it's incompatible with a
lot of philosophical uh speculation that
you could have parallel multiple
universes in fact they may not be even
distant from us just like they may be in
very closely related to us or they may
be us in the sense of what's called many
worlds Multiverse interpretation so the
stakes are very high it's the most
primitive thing this is why I'm so
interested this is why I do what I do
because to study where everything came
from where potentially as Stephen
Hawking said asking what came before the
Big Bang is meaningless as asking what's
north of the North Pole he may have been
wrong surprisingly uh he may have been
wrong no it would be very interesting I
asked I would say to ask God if God
exists to say what happened on the
Tuesday before the Big Bang that may
have an answer for the first time in
history by technology that my colleagues
who are far smarter than I am are
helping to build via What's called the
Simon's Observatory which is located
it's actually one one of the if not the
highest altitude construction project in
the world building a massive telescope
array
130 million dollar project funded
primarily by the Simons foundation in
Manhattan New York and this is to
unravel what caused the bang was there a
big banger or was it all a spontaneous
fluke and if it was a big bang are there
other universes parallel to ours in a
sense I think you know for me it's one
of the most exciting things to Grapple
with when are we going to find out well
if you join my webinar
uh so the the challenging thing is that
these things take time we're almost done
with construction we have colleagues
that are there right now in Chile this
is in the Atacama Desert 5200 meters
above sea level 17 000 feet above sea as
I said highest observatory in the world
the highest construction project in the
world higher than you know the base
station permanent base station Mount
Everest very challenging conditions uh
very low oxygen extreme ultraviolet
damage from the Sun but it does make you
know it's compared to going to Mars it's
like a cakewalk so Elon is welcome to
spend some time there are active
volcanoes next door to us
um and uh it's a very uh inhospitable
place we're delayed by the pandemic a
year and a half two three years which
costs money because you can't just say
well I know you're going to get your PhD
working in the Keating laboratory come
back in two and a half years when things
are you know no we couldn't do that so
we kept it going cost more money and
luckily been able to see it through so
yes we're about to get what's called
First Light when we'll get the first
astronomical data later this calendar
year 2023 and then we should have
results a year later but what I always
caution people is that we won't be able
to say
definitively we won't be able to say yes
there was definitely a singularity you
could however say that there was no
singularity in other words you can in
science you have to be careful most
people think it's like math you can
prove one plus one equals two you can
prove you guys know this that uh you
know sign is is opposite over hypotenuse
right trigonometry isn't that right you
guys know okay you can prove those
things yeah I know
it goes back to Euclid uh right so you
can prove those you can't prove
something in physics you can't prove
that you know the Big Bang but you can
rule out the other Alternatives and so
therefore you can falsify things about
uh alternative models so by discovering
the pattern that we're searching for we
would not prove the singularity but we'd
falsify the Alternatives including some
purported by Nobel Laureate and friend
of mine and your Countryman sir Roger
Penrose who has a model that's a
cyclical universe that Cycles into and
out of existence so I always say my job
is to not prove theories it's to kill
theories prove them wrong and I think
that's where it's nice to kind of marry
the theoretical with the experimental
and hopefully we unveiled new knowledge
about the origin of the only story that
had no precedent perhaps
that is absolutely fascinating Brian the
one question that I want to ask before
we finish up is this
when you see people whose knowledge of
science is so completely awry let's take
for instance something like a flat
earther
do you think it's a thought of the
individual or do you think it's the
thought of science
Ah that's a good question I first would
say it's the fault of Education
because it's very difficult although I
should say
you guys are you guys are very good at
you know self-mocking Behavior but uh
but I know that's I know because I'm a
big fan of yours that you guys are
highly intelligent it's a British thing
yeah you can't pretend to be smart yeah
otherwise people beat it out that's
right yeah okay basically yeah let's
stipulate that I want you to be honest
and then now we're getting all Diary of
a CEO and you guys which you know you
guys are gonna see who's that
dimensional okay so I'm gonna make you
guys you guys got to be real London real
no no
um could you guys prove the Earth is is
a sphere no you couldn't right no so
imagine proving that the Earth is not
the center of the solar system right
right and imagine proving the solution
is not the center of the gal anyway
um so why is that you guys are educated
people can you imagine saying ah you
know I never read Shakespeare oh I can't
spell no I mean my spell Checkers gets a
lot of work but it would never be
comfortable with that so it's a little
bit on you guys right an educated man a
woman in the 21st century should know
some of the classics it's it's like I
you know yes we can cancel anyone you
want but but to not know it it's
canceling yourself right if you don't
know these if this doesn't bother you
like how do you know that the Earth is
going around a giant ball Fusion reactor
called the sun
um so part of its education because it's
hard right people so the teachers don't
learn it they're not forced to do it and
so they don't teach the students but
also the Curiosity of the individual has
to be important and one thing I have I'm
not great at math I'm not the greatest
at buildings but I have rapacious
curiosity and I think that's the trait
that has allowed me to achieve the
modest success that I've had because I
keep wanting to answer these questions
because I keep realizing how finite my
life is so I would say you know flat
earther is just you know is a byproduct
of this if unless it's people that you
know much more passionately believe that
aliens not only exist but are actually
visiting you know parts of California
and parts of Virginia and I I've had a
lot of conversations about that on my
podcast and we'll continue because I
think it's interesting uh potentially
because it would open a portal to you
know learn about physics of a different
Century but be there something so to
answer your question France I do think
it's partially on the individual
partially on the society that's
producing the individual that giving us
so much potential technology byproduct
of basic science that nobody understands
well I think that's kind of it isn't it
because I think the the world has come
to a point where it's so complex and so
complicated uh I don't know if if you
could you you may be able to uh my
grandfather could maintain his own
vehicle yeah very few people can do that
now and it's not because necessarily
people have got Dumber it's because the
vehicle has got more complicated that's
right yeah and I think the same is true
of there are so many things you now have
to know to survive or to thrive
particularly that the amount of time you
can spend learning certain things most
people simply aren't going to be able to
dedicate that much time to that
particular thing on the other hand check
technology takes away with one hand as
you're saying the ability to change a
battery in your phone yeah good luck
with that let alone you know service the
CPU on your car but um but it gives too
right now with uh with chat GPT with
artificial intelligence which we'll talk
about some other time that element and
you guys come on my podcast helping in
Southern California uh yeah we can tell
you all about physics yeah exactly sort
you out can't wait tell them about the
Multiverse
because we're going to be a while here
but I'll win the Nobel Prize
so as an example like I'm kind of glad
that I wrote my first three books
without the help of AI because I know I
did it myself it's provable I could do
it because it didn't exist yeah um but
now that that also has become a lever
and a force multiplier for me because
now I can do stuff where I can actually
take uh say the written works of Galileo
who's one of my heroes I said I was able
to get his written words and create the
first ever audiobook by Galileo it's
kind of weird you think oh there's audio
no no one had ever done that I did it I
read it uh with with Carlo rivelli as a
famous physicist
um and uh and Lucio pichirillo and a
couple of Nobel Prize it was amazing
thing well now I can say hmm I could
take that text I have to document file
put it into a large language model then
I can start to say well what would
Galileo say about the Multiverse and
I've made a Galileo chat bot I've made a
fine bot I made an uh Einstein bot and
so I'm doing this exploring because the
question is can they then derive new
laws of physics so the people who will
win in the AI age are not the people are
like gifted with this innate ability who
has an inability to program in Python
you know with this you know JavaScript
wrapper nobody knows how to do that but
you might not need to like I'm not a
great programmer but now I can tell Bard
or Chachi write a python wrapper around
this uh this model that I get and it
will start to add I can ask Galileo what
do you think about quantum mechanics I
can do mine and then I can say well
here's all these data points from the
spectrum of exoplanet and here's 10 000
of those here's a thousand simulations
of what life could be like
compare those
and I could never have done done that
you know 20 years 10 years five years
ago so technology is giving us abilities
that we never had but what's the key
thing you have to be curious about it I
can't teach curiosity I can stimulate it
I can avoid it and as Barry barish the
same novelary I told you about he said
we have almost a negative association
when I say curiosity killed the cat
that's a bat like I don't want to kill a
cat like you murder us you know Peta
Violet right so so it's almost a
negative thing curiosity is the most
beautiful you know totally yeah human
event so when you have a child or you
have your ideological children that that
that you support and you mentor
inculcating curiosity that's a
superpower that's all we have that's our
that's our claws that's our teeth as
human beings so that's what I would want
to inculcate most of all well I agree
with you but then we come into conflict
with I suppose what we were talking
about at the beginning which is the
Curiosity to explore right
um well I suppose it's different when it
costs you trillions of dollars right and
come back with me because I I want to
finish that conversation actually or at
least do more on it which is you
mentioned education but stem education
will then produce more scientists and
more engineers and and so on who will
want to go to Mars right so I my sense
from what you're saying is that you you
think that a lot of the way we think we
want to use science to to fill a void
that actually gets to be filled by other
things while we're here down here on
Earth
a lot of that is is I would agree with I
would say that there's a there's a
meaning Gap yes that can't be filled by
technology yes and it can only be filled
ironically by reverence for the past
so in other words when you think about
um you know like the the worship of the
young that we have nowadays and Tick
Tock the Instagram the Snapchat and and
even with these AIS and so like just
like every second on Twitter it's like
some new get rich I can't keep up with
it or like follow these 10 tips
um and before that was web three Bitcoin
it goes on and on and so there's this
Future Shock that older people feel
um and yet we are the only repositories
of whiz I say we you know I'm older than
you guys right but but the point being
that you have to have a reverence and
and in the age where you kill God
there's no reverence who cares about
some book that was written 3200 years
ago had even if it was written by God
whatever it's out of date but certainly
it was written by man like it's totally
irrelevant like I have the scene in my
book where I kind of you know take down
the Nobel Prize through most of the book
and try to build it up towards the very
end because I think if it doesn't get
reformed if we have more joke Nobel
prizes or things that are it's gonna
collapse under its own weight you know
the Pulitzer Prize used to be way more
prestigious yeah you talked about this
in Michael Allison like the Pulitzer
Prize used to be really prestigious
um
most kids don't know what a Pulitzer
prizes but the Nobel Prize people still
the same danger can befall the Nobel
Prize if it's not reformed in the way
that I hope in my car and the reforms I
present or nothing but anyway so I
decried this
I I write that in 2016 2017 I finished
the first draft of the book ended the
publisher and a Nobel Laureate came to
UCSD to give a talk Duncan haldane as a
Brit and he was at Princeton he actually
did the work that one of the Nobel Prize
at UC San Diego where I am and uh he
brought his Nobel Prize with him
I was like this is weird and after his
talk people went up to it and were
kissing it people were taking selfies of
it somehow it ends up in my hand I took
us like I just written a book
and I remembered back to the scene from
Exodus in the Old Testament and the Jews
get LED out of Egypt by Moses through a
split sea after ten deadly plagues and
it's all super ridiculous miraculous and
then they get to the other side they
don't have water for a couple days and
they start to complain they're like oh
why did you take us out of Egypt were
there not enough graves in Egypt that's
like classic Jewish humor like they
start complaining about the food in
Egypt we had garlic and cucumbers I'm
just like what the hell like like when
you think of as like idiots and then 40
days later after that
they build a golden calf worship it and
they say this is the god that led you
out of Egypt that they were just let out
it was 40 days ago in other words the
attraction to idolatry is very very
strong in human beings we can't
comprehend what it was like I mean a
rabbi once told me it was like the
sexual urge and a man you know a
straight or gay right it's like it's
almost overpowered we have to control
that as good men in society right
um and that was what it was like to
worship but we still worship idols
wealth education Prestige followers uh
ratings advertise all these things we
still we're just as idolatrous as ever
how would we know that well we have to
go back and read and have some
connection and reverence for wisdom not
I'm not saying let's look at the
technology of the 32nd Century no I'm
way I'm in love with technology but it's
addictive and it's worshipful it's
dangerous because it becomes a false
idol and that's well the second
commandment we're born against that and
one of the things I'm hearing in that
which I find very interesting is we
confuse knowledge with wisdom and we
think because we live in a world where
all the knowledge of the universe is at
our fingertips that means that all the
wisdom of the universe is our fingertips
that's right one maybe it's not that's
absolutely not right and even going back
and reading great literature not not
only reading the Bible reading you know
the great literature of of civilization
and and asking yes what can we do with
that and the conflation of that you know
they all joke that you know knowledge is
knowing a tomato is a fruit but wisdom
is not putting it in a fruit salad you
know it's there's some truth to that uh
but but never more so when we think that
you know I I happen to think again we
keep talking about Elon I think he's
very smart I don't you know he may be
wise I I haven't met him I haven't
talked to him but just as I said that
one thing the one question the first
question I would ask him is who are you
going to leave behind
I don't I don't think I think he is a
good father I see him in pictures with
his with a little X and whatever
as a as a man as a father
is that what you're willing to give up
like why how how will you explain it to
him because you're not going to take him
so those are the those are kind of the
questions
um you know that that I'm most curious
about and so that's where I want to get
knowledge is cheap knowledge can be
found anywhere Wikipedia knows way more
than any of us will ever know but wisdom
is extremely precious and it's highly
highly undervalued asset unique to human
beings now that is a good point to
finish on Professor Brian Keating as
always the last question we ask is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about that we really should be as a
society I think the the preciousness the
uh the fact that we're likely alone I
think it inspires Terror and I think
things that terrify people there's a
book by Ernest Becker the denial of
death
we don't like to think about it we build
monuments we build pharaohs and
sarcophagi and pyramids we build Nobel
prizes we do all these things to mark
this little speck of a DOT that we
inhabit when intermitting is available
to everyone no matter how wealthy or
poor you might be and I think developing
those connections to me and putting at
risk the
potential consequences
of personal devastation
and it seems ironic I'm advocating that
you should be vulnerable to Devastation
no no because any of us that are parents
can contemplate in a nanosecond the most
devastating thing that we can imagine I
won't even say it it brings me into
tears to think about it whatever a
parent has every parent has it I don't
know you and I are just beaming this
back we know what we're talking about I
don't have to say a damn thing and you
know
but that's a very powerful guidepost
it's telling you to lean into those
things what's important that if taken
away would devastate you I don't think
we like to talk about that and I think
that and thinking in that way of
bridging gaps and maybe you know not to
make this you know two Lex friedmanish
but to to bring this interpersonal
connectedness that we are part of this
vast network of humanity
uh that will bring love this nature of
distribution of love because every
person you add to a network it increases
geometrically and exponentially to make
those connections make the deepest
connections such that if they're taken
away
you can't Envision what life would be
like lean into those that's what we
should be talking about that's really
valuable I appreciate that Brian
[Music]
foreign